looks like we're doing the mission
zombie attack tell me everything's quiet
and we have time to take a day off
hardly you have a meeting with the mayor
coming up soon mayor when did I make
that meeting yes I did before Philippe
or through the mayor for years I thought
the Saints would like the same
opportunity you weren't helping he's the
mayor believe me he's worth it all right
yeah I need a car to their cars what
they're just callin chase s alright
thanks for the lift I got y'all like 10
years away do this so far away what the
heck
yeah hey
what the [ __ ] ah cynics on lying
are so slow
I mean motorcycle
huh oh [ __ ] ah he's serious rah rah rah
Jesus
and I get back to the [ __ ] where
there again oh my god okay can i call
now for Jesus know which are we ready to
do this spring car right yeah let's do
this guy's get it
what the [ __ ] it's gonna work
I guess it did
it's like this is a restricted zone but
it's [ __ ] everyone in here
sounds like really read a training Jesus
no person would have cut this out right
huh
nada gunfire
yeah Harry got her go what do we lose
Yuma script me we're not walking in
there until you promise to play nice
he's serious repeat after me don't [ __ ]
with the mayor look sweetie I'll [ __ ]
with whoever I want to [ __ ] with hey
who's this guy think he is viola is this
the kid you were talking about poor
[ __ ] rental what who else could keep
this town running besides I love my
constituents sir I am a huge fan excuse
me viola says the Saints had a new game
in town if that's the case I want in uh
yeah great what do you need I got a
zombie problem that I want weight of
what problem zombie yeah you mean
metaphorically this celebrity-obsessed
mediadrug masses yes you st. Los Angeles
I'll tell you about it later you knew
about this so what do you think it that
cleanup ain't exactly in our wheelhouse
but yeah we'll give it a whirl I'm sure
worried about pissing off stag you're
acting like I never had outsmart a
paramilitary organization before call me
when it's done okay oh my god this guy
is [ __ ] awesome stop being a fanboy
gone somewhere I am a mother for sure
not sure this was the best idea it's too
late now you don't back out after green
to something with the mayor I could
never let her down
there's no way I can do this what's the
plan here gas masks chemicals get
neutralized zombies get killed but for
killing with zombies what's the plan for
that shoot them until they stop moving
sure that's not
Oh
heard from eye contact and stag there
are three containers leaking the virus
into the air they'll have to be
submerged in water to be neutralized
think you could handle that I have the
perfect tool for the job okay I guess to
scrape this is quick
what the [ __ ] of that yeah the friggin
week they're like weaker than the
average person how do I [ __ ] get to
them ouch eka eka laughing over there
okay talk a lot of them oh Jesus will
vary got a breath okay I
well ah ok
ok
here's to do this okay one amazing oh my
god surprise [ __ ] [ __ ] can I climb this
now
let's hope they get back out always up
here
now go now that's a viola a lot of
[ __ ] zombies gotta say that though
okay i guess no just arriving there I
should a lot about
yeah how are you she hide in here
split up when zombies are involved
what's going to say thanks
she has how many [ __ ] zombies are
here I can [ __ ] it we gotta keep moving
nice girls couldn't even kill something
that's dead I'm dead how scientific
manufacturing zombie gas dust invaded
killing yeah
okay I was wrong I sticks forever
haha
hey [ __ ] lobbies are here
okay I'm getting dizzy let me check it
[ __ ] mouth-on-mouth damage plus five
maybe I can fix it there no I give me
here
shut okay I'm running I'm running
and a [ __ ] Reagan
my salmon runs out so quickly
ok
okay i protect the hell up shut chat
you should we hung my lock oh [ __ ]
oh god this is our right that's a
problem I'm getting hungry relax I
could've been worse
I guys got OSHA damning I can't get
what's gone now shut sorry
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] it sound like I'm fire a
lot kind of gone
ok ok I gonna make it
who has so far one chance
go I'm I've gone get get
tell me there won't be any problem
another container to in their world but
you get this done he could count on a
scale port municipality to back Saints
SWAT teams favors from the police chief
a little help from me personally
whatever you need
I'm saying since the great songs to
fight with us overwhelming our enemies
within time to flesh well you do have a
point but let's get curb-stomped
now I'm gonna pair it did I don't want
[ __ ] Bobby always
wait are you gonna jump of course
he's like let the fact they're having
some complication Center you want
results that authorize the use of the
Daedalus security was never control
zombies and Monica Hughes hmm ok zombie
no thanks ROG
it's out for her Amish